[Música]
qué pasaría si las cosas hablarán de
historias tendrían para contarnos si nos
ponemos a pensar no existen momentos sin
objetos estamos rodeados todo el día de
toda clase de cosas que cambian nuestra
vida para bien o para mal
un hogar en eeuu promedio tiene
aproximadamente 300.000 objetos
un niño inglés de 12 años juega con 238
juguetes tiene 238 juguetes y juega sólo
con 12 desafortunadamente tenemos cada
vez relaciones más cortas y más
superficiales que no nos dejan
conectarnos con los objetos que no nos
dejan conocerlos para poder buscar la
satisfacción a través de ellos crecí en
una familia donde todo se hace a mano
desde chiquita aprendí a coser aprendí a
tejer aprendí a desarmar las cosas para
volver a armar las entendí de alguna
manera la complejidad que es crear con
las manos los tiempos que llevan los
procesos de aprendizaje los éxitos y los
fracasos pero también aprendí que yo
misma podría transformar el mundo que yo
tenía la capacidad de tomar esos
materiales y esas cosas que llegaban a
mí y convertirlos en lo que yo quería
estudia diseño industrial en la tarde o
como muchos de ustedes buscando un poco
poder entender ese proceso más allá de
mi experiencia personal puede entender
como todos esos productos que llegaban a
mí eran configurados y eran creados a
través de mi carrera entendí que los
diseñadores buscan una problemática
reúnen un grupo de personas y ese grupo
personas buscan cuál es la necesidad que
tienen cuál es el problema que tienen y
buscan resolverlo juntamos con todas
nuestras herramientas la mejor manera
posible de poder ayudar a solventar ese
problema sin embargo no siempre podemos
tener en cuenta y no siempre tenemos en
cuenta qué pasa con los objetos cuando
ya están en la mano de alguien más hay
algunas personas que las usan como
nosotros lo proyectamos exactamente de
la manera como yo diseñé el objeto para
que funcionara hay personas que compran
objetos los usan un tiempo y no logran
adaptarse a ellos y acaban votando los o
guardando los y hay una cantidad de
personas distintas que usan los objetos
de maneras creativas que usan los
objetos de maneras diferentes
y obtener exactamente la misma cosa y
usarla de una manera completamente
diferente
estos son mis dos hijos pedro y mateo
hace unos meses les compré una caja con
carritos les encantan los carritos y
llegué yo muy emocionada con mi regalo a
la casa lo desempacaron sacaron los
carritos a un lado y empezaron a jugar
con la caja porque un niño de un año de
tres años prefiere jugar con una caja
que fueron diseñados para que ellos
pudieran jugar
la caja puede ser cualquier cosa en esa
tarde esa caja se volvió un carrito se
volvió en escondite se volvió en casita
se volvió en todo lo que ellos estaban
imaginando y lo que ellos querían que
fuera el hombre es un hombre
transformador desde chiquitos tenemos
esa necesidad de transformar de crear el
mundo preferimos las cosas que no vienen
acabadas preferimos poder modificarlas
por eso nos interesa jugar con el ego
por ejemplo cómo podemos construir a
partir de un objeto que no me está
diciendo lo que es y me da la
posibilidad de que yo lo transforme
con eso en mente con la idea en mente de
que el hombre es transformador y tiene
la capacidad de crear el mundo como él
quiere empecé a viajar a comunidades
indígenas alrededor del país tuve la
oportunidad de trabajar con las
fundaciones no ya no en el
fortalecimiento de las cadenas
artesanales de grupos de artesanos
indígenas en el vichada en el guainía en
el vaupés y en el amazon
este proceso me enseñó muchas cosas
digamos que inicialmente cuando uno
llega a las comunidades uno encuentra
dos tipos de objetos distintos los
objetos con lo que yo estaba trabajando
que eran objetos artesanales que
normalmente son objetos que ellos hacen
para vender a otras personas esos
objetos tienen unas características y
unos acabados particulares pero hay otra
cantidad de objetos que empiezan a ver
en las comunidades cuando convive con
ellos qué son los objetos que están
haciendo para ellos mismos y esos
objetos un poco me remitieron a esos
procesos que hacía yo cuando era
chiquita de crear de como uno crea para
uno mismo y al crear para uno mismo hace
unos procesos muy diferentes a cuando lo
está creando para otra persona en estas
comunidades se encuentran una cantidad
de canastos me atrajo decir que en todas
las comunidades de colombia y
probablemente en todas las comunidades
del mundo se encuentran canastos el
canasto es un objeto básico que permite
cargar o almacenar cosas a primera vista
los canastos pueden ser muy parecidos
pero cuando uno empieza a ir más allá y
empieza a hablar con los canastos ya
descubrir qué historias tienen para
contar se da cuenta que son muy
diferentes
este canasto que ven acá es un canasto
carguero de una comunidad o carne de la
amazona
este canasto se utiliza para cargar los
alimentos desde los cultivos hasta las
comunidades pero cuando uno ve un
canasto así y empieza a preguntarse qué
cosas nos cuenta primero empezamos a
hablar de todo el tema del conocimiento
y el territorio alfredo es el artesano
que tejió el canasto para tejer ese
canasto alfredo tuvo que haber aprendido
acerca de su territorio tuvo que tener
el conocimiento para encontrar que
materias primas
en este caso el viejo collar están
disponibles como se preparan esas
materias primas para poder tejer y luego
con qué técnicas artesanales
tradicionales podemos convertirlo en
este
de alguna manera más allá de lo que se
usa el canasto este canasto no se
empieza a hablar de una comunidad no se
empieza a hablar de la cultura o karina
y nos empieza a todo el territorio del
amazonas en donde ellos se encuentran
adicionalmente es un canasto que
funciona probablemente para que este
canasto se volviera en un objeto
tradicional de esa comunidad un proceso
largo de ensayo y error en que se
ensayaron a tejer las fibras para lograr
el objeto perfecto y en el momento en
que se creó este canasto que ya lleva
reproduciéndose de generación en
generación se convirtió en un canasto
tradicional este canal solo tejió
alfredo para su esposa su esposa rosy
está la de trae los alimentos desde el
conuco o el cultivo hasta la comunidad
ella lo carga en la cabeza se lo cuelga
en la cabeza y lo lleva colgando atrás y
de alguna manera mientras ella va
caminando es un canasto suficientemente
resistente para poder cargar toda la
yuca pesada pero también los huecos del
canasto permiten que la tierra vaya
saliendo y al mismo tiempo el hecho de
que tenga una estructura abierta hace
que las otras personas de la comunidad
puedan ver el resultado de los cultivos
de esa familia es un canasto que se
modifica con la familia que lo usan los
diferentes miembros cuando una persona
es más bajita la tira se acorta cuando
es más larga se arregla se alarga en los
casos en que el canasto empieza a tener
algunas fallas los artesanos conocen la
técnica que conocen el material para
poder remendarlo y transformarlo cuantas
sea posible y finalmente cuando ya no
cumple con la misma función con la
resistencia para seguir cargando la yuca
desde los cultivos empieza a cumplir
otras funciones entonces es un canasto
que ya no tiene la misma presión pero se
puede utilizar como basurero para
guardar otros objetos o para la ropa
sucia entonces alguna manera este tipo
de objetos evolucionan con la familia
representan no solamente a una cultura
con todas sus características sino que
representan también a unas personas a
unas personas que tienen ciertas
actividades y en este caso una familia
completa
qué pasa cuando un objeto que está
creado y diseñado perfecto para un
contexto y para una familia cambia de
contexto
en este caso el canasto me lo regaló
alfredo y yo me lo llevé para bogotá y
el canasto llegó a bogotá muy desubicado
porque claro yo no iba andar con un
canasto en la cabeza por bogotá no tenía
un cultivo para traer mis cosas sin
embargo las mismas características del
objeto puestas dentro de mi contexto y
con mis necesidades empezaron a aparecer
nuevos usos para el objeto entonces en
mi caso se volvieron en los canastos en
los que se guardan los juguetes de mis
niños de alguna manera los objetos
tienen múltiples vidas y valores tienen
la capacidad de transformarse en las
manos de las personas que los usan y yo
y ustedes tienen la capacidad de
los objetos y convertirlos en lo que
ustedes quieren que sea
y obsesione con el tema de los contextos
y como los contextos cambian los objetos
y cuando hablamos de un contexto
pensamos si en un espacio geográfico
pero pensamos sobre todo en las personas
y en las actividades que se están dando
dentro de dicho contexto
decidí cambiar de contexto yo misma y me
fui a estudiar una maestría en
antropología para empezar a mirar estos
objetos con unos ojos no del diseño sino
desde las relaciones sociales de las
personas y empecé a estudiar una
cantidad de objetos muy curiosos que ya
no nos hablan de cómo un objeto
tradicional llega a bogotá sino como de
un objeto de bogotá llega un contexto
tradicional en este caso estamos
hablando de un tarro de aceite
juntaron aceite cuya función
inicialmente simplemente es guardar el
aceite digamos que lo que vale del tarro
de aceite es lo que está dentro y no el
objeto como tal pero cuando llega al
vichada y se encuentra con unos niños
amor uva que no tienen juguetes empieza
a forma de carrito y los niños
tienen la capacidad de transformar en lo
que ellos necesitan entonces para un
objeto como este tarro de aceite que
hubiéramos considerado basura en un
contexto como el nuestro tiene la
capacidad de convertirse en el objeto
más valioso de un niño y es bonito ver
en estas comunidades como no solamente
hay un carrito todos los niños les gustó
la idea y acabaron haciendo los mismos
carritos y encontrar una botella que
para muchos hubiera sido basura se
convierte en un descubrimiento
maravilloso para el uso y para el
contexto de esos niños
de alguna manera los objetos no están
acabados así nosotros ya dejemos de
tener les digamos que algún valor
particular hay otras personas que pueden
encontrar el valor de los objetos y de
la misma manera nosotros mismos podemos
descubrir valores en cosas inesperadas
a partir de todas mis conversaciones con
los objetos decidí que tenía que
dedicarme a contar las historias que
había detrás
todo esto llevó a iniciar un proyecto
que se llama no laboratorio creativo en
el cual experimentamos descontextualiza
vamos hacemos mezclamos materiales el
objetivo es jugar con las cosas es jugar
con los materiales los objetos y las
técnicas para poder crear cosas nuevas y
empezar a valorarlo de hecho a mano
llevamos dos años conversando con estos
canastos de suncho
a primera vista
es un canasto de mercado probablemente
muchos de ustedes los han visto en las
plazas de mercado en bogotá y en otras
ciudades en muchos casos se encuentra
uno personas en las calles de bogotá
vendedores ambulantes que llevan su
tinto sus termos de tinto y de agua
panela para poder vender por la calle en
general es un objeto tejido y es
interesante para este tipo de contextos
porque es resistente y porque es muy
colorido pero si uno empieza a mirar un
poco más allá y a descubrir qué es lo
que este canasto nos puede contar
empieza a darse cuenta que primero que
todo tiene que haber un artesano tiene
que haber alguien que lo hizo y en ese
sentido aparecen una cantidad de
historias adicionales alrededor del
canasto de suncho este artesano que ven
acá es orlando orlando es un artesano
que viajó desde el huila era artesano en
su región y cuando llegó a bogotá no
tenía los mismos materiales para
trabajar de alguna manera encontró en la
ciudad un material muy interesante que
es el sueño el sueño simplemente la
cinta plástica con las que se amarran
las cajas para poder transportar y
sostener la caja mientras llega de un
lugar a otro cuando este material llega
a bogotá a la caja sede se empaca y el
suyo queda votado como basura
orlando encontró que este material tenía
características muy parecidas a las de
los materiales con el que estaba
trabajando en su comunidad y se puso a
jugar y ensayo a tejer y aparece el
canasto de suncho como un resultado de
esa conexión entre un material
totalmente urbano con un conocimiento
tradicional artesanal entonces el
canasto va mucho más allá de ser
simplemente un objeto de uso y se
convierte en una historia de como un
artesano cambia de contexto y más allá
de eso nos habla de un país como
colombia en donde las personas están
viajando del campo a la ciudad los
materiales se están moviendo de un lado
para el otro y de alguna manera esto
genera efectos en las cosas materiales y
nos muestra como las personas tienen la
intención de poder cambiar esas
realidades nuevas en las que están
apareciendo y convertirlas en algo que
sea interesante para ellos
en realidad empezamos a trabajar con los
pinchos un poco por accidente asistimos
a una feria de artesanías en las que
vendíamos nuestras piezas de cerámica y
unos días antes no teníamos en que
llevar los productos y estábamos
pensando que si alguien compraba mucho
la bolsa de papel no iba a ser
suficiente para sostener el peso de la
cerámica a mí se me ocurrió siempre me
había interesado en los canastos de
suncho por la ironía de lo tradicional
con lo industrial se me ocurrió irme al
7 de agosto y comprar los canastos de
suncho tal cual estaban en la plaza los
llevé para la feria y para nuestra
sorpresa se vendieron más canastos de
suncho que cerámica entonces qué pasa
cuando un objeto de éstos cambia de
contexto un canasto de sancho tiene la
capacidad de pasar de ser simplemente un
objeto popular a volverse en un objeto
de moda que yo puedo usar como cartera o
como bolso de playa en un contexto
completamente distinto entonces de
alguna manera a partir de esto nació
todo un proyecto empezar a reconocer y
crear nuevos valores de los objetos y el
suyo se volvió en uno de los proyectos
más importantes de la mano hoy en día
trabajamos con artesanos
hacemos diseños nuevos y metemos
materiales diferentes cambiamos las
formas y se ha convertido en un producto
increíblemente se vende a nivel nacional
internacional de una manera que nunca no
lo hubiéramos esperado quiero invitarlos
a ustedes hoy a conversar con sus
objetos ojalá llegaran a su casa y
fueran conscientes de con qué cosas se
están relacionando que les dicen esas
cosas qué historias tienen para
contarles empezar a mirar cuáles de esos
objetos están contentos con ustedes y
cuáles están bravos cuáles de esos
objetos ustedes usan constantemente y
cuáles tienen un poco abandonados los
invito a conocer esos objetos para poder
transformarlos y para poder dejarse
transformar por ellos
[Música]